da sind wir wieder mit einer
historischen Sendung es ist nämlich die
letzte Sendung in der unsere
Scheinwerfer zu 6% mit Atomstrom
betrieben werden ja
deswegen habe ich oft so grünlich
ausgesehen falls sie sich gefragt hat
ist vorbei
das Ende einer Ära die verbleibenden
drei AKWs werden morgen ausgeknipst also
so
stelle ich mir das als laie-technisch
vor nach einem Ausstieg einem Ausstieg
aus dem Ausstieg und einem Ausstieg vom
Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg kommt jetzt
der endgültige Ausstieg muss zugeben ich
bin irgendwo unterwegs geistig
ausgestiegen
deutsche Kernenergie nur noch Geschichte
aber hat das doch alles so euphorisch
angefangen hier mit meiner rechten Hand
übergebe ich euch das magische Feuer des
Atoms kann ein Reaktor zu heiß werden
gefährlich werden
durchgehen
nein
das glaube ich nicht
Energie
ja sie lachen aber das war wirklich ein
Klassiker in den 70ern der Film hieß
atommädchenreport 7
bis der Brennstab glüht
ja
Atomkraft ist und bleibt eine
hochrisikotechnologie mit einem
ungelösten Müllproblem der Ausstieg ist
also an sich richtig über das Timing
kann man trefflich streiten mitten in
einer weltweiten Energiekrise wäre es
jetzt auf drei bis fünf Jahre mehr Müll
eigentlich nicht angekommen aber klar
muss man dazu sagen so ein grünes
Nervenkostüm ist halt auch nicht endlos
belastbar ja was was die Grünen in
letzter Zeit alles schlucken mussten
irgendwann geht's nicht mehr nervlich ne
das ist ja so
und dann fällt dir auch gar nicht mehr
auf wenn du bei Interviews in der
Ukraine aus Versehen schlimme
rhetorische Eigentore schießt keine wird
an der Atomkraft festhalten das ist
völlig klar das ist auch in Ordnung
solange die Dinger sich erlaufen die
sind ja gebaut
ja die drei die wir morgen abschalten
waren eigentlich auch schon gebaut
verglichen mit denen in der Ukraine auch
ganz schön sicher ich behaupte sogar
gerade wir Deutschen hatten immer
top-sicherheitskonzepte für unsere
Reaktoren
Strahlengefahr wird mit diesen Knöpfen
eine Sirene ausgelöst und wenn es brennt
[Musik]
dann fährt Bäckermeister Berchtold als
Feuermelder durchs Dorf und remmingen
und bläst Alarm
[Musik]
ja sie lachen aber ich sag mal so
Bäckermeister Berchtold hat besser
funktioniert als die Nina warn App
und bevor sie zu Hause jetzt doch zu
nostalgisch werden wir haben ja noch
eine Weile was von unseren AKWs der
Rückbau dauert Jahrzehnte Experten
immerhin ist die immerhin ist die
Bundesnetzagentur optimistisch in Sachen
Versorgungssicherheit also wenn wir
unsere Ausbauziele bei den regenerativen
erreichen dann müssen wir den Anteil im
Strommix von der 46 % innerhalb der
nächsten 7 Jahre auf 80% steigern wenn
wir genug wasserstofffähige gaskaffee
gebaut und wenn europäische Nachbarn im
Notfall weiter aushelfen
ganz
herzlich willkommen zur größten
Außenwette aller Zeiten Deutschland
wettet dass es gleichzeitig aus
Atomkraft und Kohle aussteigen kann top
die Wette geht Worte Opa ich bin noch
gar nicht fertig und das alles während
Robert Philosophie Student aus
Schleswig-Holstein versucht mit einem
auf Biergläsern stehendem Bagger ein
Atommüll Endlager auszuheben das eine
Million Jahre hält also die gefüllte
Länge einer normalen Betten das Sendung
und jetzt zum Betteinsatz wenn
Deutschland das nicht schafft dann
hoppla ja aber bevor sie zu Hause jetzt
Panik kriegen und Strom Hamstern
Blackout sind sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
unverbindliche Anregungen vielleicht für
den nächsten Ausstieg vielleicht doch
erst wetterunabhängige Backup Kraftwerke
bauen und dann aussteigen ist ebenmäßig
ist ebenmäßig wenn überhaupt hätte man
letzten Sommer neue Brennstäbe bestellen
müssen fast alle unsere Nachbarn
verlängern Laufzeiten oder bauen sogar
neue AKWs wie die Franzosen zum Beispiel
die machen das
ja das verschlingt allerdings unfassbare
Summen und von den 56 französischen
Reaktoren sind ein Viertel gerade außer
Betrieb weil sie gewartet werden oder
Sicherheitsmängel haben finanziell ist
Kernkraft eh ein Desaster gleichzeitig
aber halt sehr sehr emissionsarm oder in
den Worten des slowakischen
Wirtschaftsministers und mal ganz
ehrlich zu sein
ich kann nicht verstehen wie man so dumm
sein kann dass man seine eigenen
atommeller abschaltet die voll
funktionsfähig sind Alter der hat uns
dumm genannt
ich würde ihn gerne zurück beleidigen
aber vielleicht müssen wir uns bald bei
Ihnen Strom leihen ja es ist ja so der
Deutsche Weg wird kein leichter sein vor
allem fürs Klima meine Damen und Herren
ja ist also schon im letzten Jahr schon
im letzten Jahr haben wir 19
Kohlekraftwerke reaktiviert 19
gleichzeitig wollen die Grünen aber 2030
aus der Kohle raus sein damit die Bürger
da noch mitkommen muss man
wahrscheinlich wirklich das Kiffen
legalisieren
apropos kiffen frage ich mich gerade was
wird jetzt aus den Anti AKW Aktivisten
die ihr ganzes Leben gegen Atomkraft
gekämpft haben klar erst haben sie sich
natürlich tierisch gefreut über den
Erfolg aber jetzt sieht man leider immer
öfter wie diese Veteranen
orientierungslos durch unsere Straßen
irren sie leiden unter Posten nuklearer
Belastung Störung manche kleben sich
schon auf der Straße fest und labern die
letzte Generation voll was das Dorf 86
das war eine Demo 44 Wasserwerfer haben
die eingesetzt und aus dem Hubschrauber
haben die Bullen Tränengas auf uns
runtergeworfen ich weiß nicht ich habe
damals zu meinem Kollegen aus
Verzweiflung selber von der Straße
schneiden weil sie es einfach nicht mehr
aushalten
[Applaus]
Alter wo sollen die jetzt alle hin ja
die Anti akadem Bewegung aufgeschichte
ja der deutsche Sonderweg in Sachen
Energie und übrigens falls Sie zu Hause
auch Schwierigkeiten haben unsere
Strategie da im Detail zu verstehen
empfehle ich Ihnen ganz dringend einen
Besuch im schönen Brunsbüttel German
Energiewende in der nachtschelle hier
hinter mir auf dem Gelände da soll dann
das feste dauerhafte energy Terminal
entstehen da liegt aber gerade noch jede
Menge Kohle die auch für Strom wird
unter einem Windrad gleich neben einem
stillgelegten Atomkraftwerk und eine
Zwischenlager für Atomabfälle
Memo an mich selbst Urlaub in
Brunsbüttel stornieren
ja ja bei den neuen LNG Terminals da
klappt das mit dem Deutschland Tempo
leider aber nur da demnächst auch auf
Rügen muss der arme Kaspar David
Friedrich sein berühmtes Bild noch mal
von vorne malen es ist es ist typisch
typisch deutsche Überkompensation
jahrelang haben wir gar nichts gemacht
beim Flüssiggas jetzt muss uns die EU
schon erahnen weil wir zu viele
Terminals bauen mit einer Kapazität von
76 Milliarden Kubikmeter Flüssiggas pro
Jahr obwohl man eigentlich nur die 55
ersetzen müsste die wir früher bei Putin
gekauft haben über Kompensation ja
Moment sagt habe ich an diesem Terminals
da kommt ja ein paar Jahren praktisch
nur noch grüner Wasserstoff an ja
Wasserstoff das ist
Wasserstoff ist der neue heiße Scheiß
alles auf grünem Wasserstoff basiert
alles auf Wasserstoff damit sollen wir
demnächst sogar Heizen wird schon in
wenigen Jahren ausreichend Wasserstoff
zur Beheizung von Gebäuden zur Verfügung
stehen davon ist leider nicht auszugehen
das ja blöd
da hat man jetzt so ein bisschen drauf
gesetzt kann man nicht einen anderen
Experten fragen nein schade ja
tatsächlich ist es so dass erstmal die
Industrie den öko-wasserstoff braucht
und da bleibt dann vermutlich wenig
übrig für uns also für private Haushalte
mal ganz abgesehen vom Preis keiner weiß
was Wasserstoff mal kosten wird weil es
den Markt noch gar nicht gibt fürs
Wunder Elixier
wasserstoff-shopping Europe günstiger
Wasserstoff rund um die Uhr
da sind wir wieder liebe Zuschauer und
ich will ganz ehrlich sein ich habe hier
schon den hinteren letzten Quatsch
vertickt aber dieses Produkt ist echt
der Wahnsinn dr Roberts grüner
Wasserstoff für und gegen alles ein
hammerzeug sie können damit ihre
Industrie klimaneutral machen ihre
Wohnung heizen Autos voll tanken Schiffe
Oliver und jetzt passen sie mal gut auf
dieses T-Shirt da sind die schlimmsten
Flecken drauf ein Blut Kakao so und wenn
ich da jetzt mit dr Roberts Wasserstoff
ja das ist Wasser natürlich das enthält
auch Wasserstoff das ist richtig aber
grünen Wasserstoff gibt's noch so gut
wie gar nicht nur ein Prozent des
weltweit hergestellten Wasserstoffs wird
mit Ökostrom gemacht
die haben völliga das ist ein super Zeug
äh bitte nicht sofort bestellen liebe
Zuschauer wir kriegen die erste
Lieferung rein im Jahr
ja ist ja auch egal Deutschlands Energie
Zukunft hängt ab von der flore oder hat
irgendeine bessere Idee absolut wenn man
Hühnerkot zu Energie machen kann bestens
ja Hühnerkot habe ich auch da
Robert Hühner Scheiße Sekunde hole ich
gerade nee lassen Sie mal lassen Sie mal
ich sag mal so wenn alle weltweit
geplanten Öko wasserstoffprojekte
realisiert würden landen wir 2030
vielleicht bei 24 Millionen Tonnen
Produktion im Jahr für die Klimaziele
bräuchte aber 100 Millionen ja ja
whatever aber schauen Sie sich mal
dieses T-shirt an
wo sind denn jetzt die ganzen Flecken
hin alle weg danke dr Roberts grünen
Wasserschaden natürlich der ist so
schwer zu transportieren bei der
Herstellung geht unfassbar viel Energie
verloren und der weltweite Bedarf kann
den absehbarer Zeit nie gedeckt werden
es ist eine Energie Strategie als ob man
das als ob man aus dem Flugzeug springt
und in dem Weg nach unten und sie
fliegen gerne eine Weile bis unten
ankommen diskutieren sie wie nähen wir
ein Fallschirm und argumentieren bevor
wir unten sind ist der falsche fertig
das kann funktionieren vielleicht ist ja
auch fertig aber ich würde es trotzdem
nicht ausprobieren wollen
natürlich wollen wir das Ausprobieren ja
weil wir Deutschen spontan sind ein Volk
von Abenteurern no risk no fun was liebe
Zuschauer wenn sie jetzt nur 50
Millionen Tonnen grünen Wasserstoff
vorbestellen bekommen sie von mir
diesen Fallschirm gratis dazu und ich
muss bekloppt sein
diesen gucken ja ja schon Weihnachten
nein ist es nicht im Moment gibt's fast
nur grauen Wasserstoff der wird mit
Erdgas produziert ja aber nicht nur das
wir haben auch jede Menge pinken
Wasserstoff der wird mit Atomkraft
hergestellt
Atomkraft inzwischen arbeiten Forscher
sogar schon an braunem Wasserstoff in
fester Form können Sie bei sich zu Hause
im Keller stapeln das ist Kohle nein das
ist brauner Wasserstoff so und jetzt
kommt der eigentliche Burner wenn Sie
liebe Zuschauer unter Haarausfall leiden
und sich dann dr Roberts Wasserstoff
einfach direkt auf die Geheimratsecken
nein dürfen sie nicht meine Damen und
Herren
[Applaus]
Wasserstoff Shopping New York günstiger
Wasserstoff rund um die Uhr
[Applaus]
ja gut
jetzt müssen wir dazu sagen
der Fairness halber
die Grünen haben es auch nicht leicht ne
alles was schief läuft in der Ampel
schiebt man nur denen in die Schuhe Toni
Hofreiter hat gerade gesagt letztes
Wochenende die SPD sei nicht mehr der
natürliche Bündnispartner der Grünen
verstehen sie wollen raus aus der
toxischen Beziehung ist ganz klar was da
läuft der Hofreiter baggert die CDU an
eindeutig ganz eindeutig und
ja immer das ist ja auch kein Wunder bei
der Union läuft Bombe wir haben Traum
Umfragen und sie siegen plötzlich auch
in Großstädten CDU ne gut in Berlin also
Großstädten die am Ende sind aber
immerhin
[Musik]
Friedrich Merz und das fand ich total
gut hat gerade persönlich neue
CDU-Mitglieder am Telefon begrüßt woraus
seine Partei dann dieses freche insta
Video gemacht hat
nein ja also ich freue mich darüber dass
sie Mitglied geworden sind wie ist das
zustande gekommen hat sie jemand
angesprochen oder sind sie selber auf
uns zugekommen wie ist das passiert ja
keine Ahnung
ich habe Gitarre geübt dann hat es
geklingelt und ich bin blöderweise
rangegangen
wer ist denn da überhaupt hallo
keine Ahnung was das sollte aber komm
der Herr Merz hat sich auch
weiterentwickelt finde ich oder wenn sie
mal darauf achten erhält in letzter Zeit
ganz ordentliche Reden im Bundestag und
er gibt neuerdings ganz glaubhaft den
Mann des Volkes es war ja das Thema im
Netz März macht ein Praktikum auf einer
Intensivstation eine ganze Frühschicht
er hat Essen verteilt Medikamente auch
an Patienten die gar keine wollten und
ja und das war aber noch nicht alles wir
gucken mal hier erschreckt er sich
furchtbar weil er denkt dass auf dem
Monitor wäre der Aktienkurs von
Blackrock aber es ist zum Glück nur das
Herzpatienten dann geht er über seine
persönliche Ecke Grenze und gibt zum
ersten Mal einer Kassenpatientin die
Hand
hier fragte eine intensivschwester was
sie eigentlich im Monat so verdient dann
hört er die Zahl und muss kurz danach
beatmet werden
ja das ist die neue CDU sozial nah bei
den Leuten und sogar für Klimaschutz ja
wirklich die neue CDU
die neue CDU hat eine Umschulung gemacht
so klimapartei natürlich cdu-style das
heißt ohne Verbote und ganz zwanglos
also so dass du es praktisch gar nicht
merkst wir sind nicht die klimakleber
der letzten Generation wir sind die
Optimisten der jüngsten Generation ja
klar
denn wenn einer glaubhaft für die
jüngste Generation sprechen kann
dann ja wohl unser Fritze tatsächlich
arbeitet seine CDU aktuell in ihrem
ersten Grundsatzprogramm seit 2007 ja
das ist ein totaler Schock für die
Partei nach all den Merkel Jahren will
man plötzlich für Inhalte stehen als CDU
statt sie wie gewohnt bei anderen
Parteien zu klauen zehn Fachgruppen
erarbeiten das neue Programm und zwar
moderiert von Carsten Linnemann den
kennen Sie garantiert er hier
vizeparteichef und motivationscoach sein
Podcast heißt übrigens wirklich einfach
mal machen und genau so meint er das
auch ein ganz kurzes Beispiel bei mir in
Paderborn soll die erste Stadt entstehen
mit autonomen fahren parallel zum
regulären Verkehr dazu gibt es in
Deutschland keine Regulierung ich kann
ihn jetzt schon sagen das dauert
wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder Jahre bis
das geht dann kommen die ganzen
Bedenkenträger und wie viel tote kann es
geben und so weiter lasst uns doch so
machen wir probieren das einfach mal aus
ja natürlich einfach mal machen
ich sag mal wenn überhaupt muss man das
in Paderborn ausprobieren ne ja was kann
im schlimmsten Fall passieren
einfach mal machen Carsten Linnemann hat
gerade in vier Regionalkonferenzen
versucht herauszufinden wie die
CDU-Basis tickt ich behaupte er weiß
selber nicht genau wofür die Partei
steht aber er findet es müssen in jedem
Fall am Ende drei Sachen sein ich möchte
gerne dass jeder nachts geweckt werden
kann und sofort weiß was sind die drei
Punkte warum ich CDU wähle am Ende
möchte ich gerne dass jedes CDU-Mitglied
nachts um 3 Uhr geweckt wird dass jedes
CDU-Mitglied nachts um 3 Uhr geweckt
wird eigentlich jedes Mitglied nachts 3
Uhr wecken jedes CDU Mitglied nachts 3
Uhr geweckt werden kann und sofort sagt
erstens dafür steht die CDU
okay
kurz zurück Frage warum nicht vier
Sachen
und warum genau um 3 Uhr es ist schwer
zu sagen aber die ziehen das knallhart
durch tatsächlich schickt die Junge
Union jetzt jede Nacht ihre Leute zu
irgendwelche CDU Mitgliedern nach Hause
und fragt nach
wofür steht die CDU was warum
wofür steht die CDU drei Sachen nicht
nachdenken
ja ich sag mal so die meisten
CDU-Mitglieder musst du gar nicht wecken
die müssen nachts eh ständig raus ne
[Musik]
Linnemann sagt die CDU braucht wieder
eine Erkennungsmelodie die Bock auf
Zukunft macht aha
ja kurzer Spoiler meinerseits auch das
neue Grundsatzprogramm wird eher wahr
bleiben warum sich ohne Not festlegen
und die CDU hat ja gerade in Berlin
bewiesen dass sie auch oldschool
gewinnen kann Erfolg indem man einfach
nur sagt die Ampel zwingt euch zu
Gendern und reißt einem die Heizung raus
ne kurz gesagt mit der södermethode es
funktioniert ja es geht ja der der Söder
Markus der Söder Markus tingelt jetzt
bis zur Bayernwahl im Oktober durch
sämtliche Bierzelte mit nur einer
einzigen Botschaft er ist das letzte
Bollwerk gegen Bauknecht aus Berlin
heraus bei uns heißt es weiß blaue Stadt
Wok wo ist
und kenzel culture
Idee ist rot tatsächlich
eine düstere wokwolke unseren
weiß-blauen Himmel zu verdunkeln um
Gottes Willen und da kommt sie auch
schon die verdammte volkwolke
sie will uns alle zu Veganern machen
fliegt zurück nach Berlin wo du
hingehörst
mein Tipp wenn der Söder im Herbst
überzeugend gewinnt tritt er garantiert
wieder an als Kanzlerkandidat im Bund
garantiert das sind die nächste
spannende Frage wer wird
unionskanzlerkandidat wir schalten mal
live zu Alexander wie Precht er leitet
im Konrad-Adenauer-Haus die geheime
Forschungsgruppe kanzlermaterial 2.0 wer
kommt denn da in Frage
also rein theoretisch erstmal jeder
gut Frauen natürlich nicht das haben wir
einmal versucht nie wieder
Wahnsinn nein nein nein aber ansonsten
gehen wir da strengen wissenschaftlich
ran hier dieses Ehepaar aus Salzgitter
repräsentiert in allen Eigenschaften
perfekt den durchschnittlichen
CDU-Wähler und den zeigen wir jetzt seit
drei Wochen die Reden von potenziellen
Kandidaten und Messen dabei ihre
Gehirnströme okay und die machen das
freiwillig mit was ja klar freiwillig
was denn sonst ist ja im Grunde Ehre ich
meine wer da schon mithelfen den
nächsten Regierungschef zu bestimmen
zusätzlich werden wir aber natürlich
auch ohne Ende Umfragedaten aus um
rauszukriegen wie sich die Deutschen den
perfekten Kandidaten vorstellen verstehe
und gibt es das schon eine erste Tendenz
sagen wir mal so einige sind schon raus
Markus Söder zum Beispiel kommt
bundesweit überhaupt nicht gut an mit
seiner Kernbotschaft alle scheiße außer
Bayern es hat sich aber rausgestellt die
meisten Deutschen Leben gar nicht in
Bayern und finden es wohl auch scheiße
wenn man sie scheiße findet und dann ist
er noch Friedrich Merz mit dem die
Wähler laut Mark Forschung nur ein Wort
verbinden
Reich
verdammt ja machst du nichts deshalb
perfekt und da lehne ich mich jetzt
einfach mal ganz weit aus dem Fenster
ist das hier
Germany's next CDU Kanzlerkandidat
wer ist das
Ministerpräsident von NRW Jungs marath
gut aussehen und rhetorisch topfit die
großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
können wir nur lösen wenn es mehr von
diesem Geist gibt
mehr mehr vom hin zum oder
mehr vom oder und weniger nein andersrum
für mehr von oder und zum Mund kommen
und da haben wir auch direkt unser
Slogan Hendrik wüst endlich vom oder zum
und kommen
stimmt der wüst aber ist ja nicht ein
bisschen zu farblos ja aber das ist doch
gerade der Witz genauso wollen die
Deutschen ihre Politiker adrett gepflegt
langweilig
keine Überraschung kein Profil wie die
CDU insgesamt und deswegen ist wüst
dieser Fleisch gewordene Bausparvertrag
der ideale Mann ich sage Startschuss zum
Wahlkampf in 3 2 1
go
so ähm und jetzt spiele ich unseren
Probanden hier noch die legendäre zwei
stündige Rede vor die Hendrik wüst
neulich bei der Eröffnung einer Umgebung
Straße in Herne gehalten hat
[Musik]
Alex vielen Dank
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig